with certain Dan bazan who lied to us
about we of mass structure we fought my
friends who died over there like you
know and I I just look what they
provided us with and it's it's not
nothing it's like a negative the Western
value and all these kind cuz you were a
party guy before yeah yeah and so was
you Eddie don't
try a lot of Muslims and they're you
know pretty morally sound for the most
part so you would consider be a Muslim I
don't know about the religion I I think
I'm probably read the
Quran brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give £10 in
donation and that £10 is used to buy
food or bricks or whatever to help the
people in Gaza but then just imagine
this amazing D that you want to do but
we turn it into a money-making machine
how the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of truear
link below and donate on a video that
just came out there was an interview you
think the Middle East and the world
would be a better place if Israel didn't
exist okay Israel's committed you know
so many terrorist attacks they they're
stealing land right now they're
operating um they're currently
committing a genocide on Palestinians
like do you believe in the genocide
they're committing I I think with
certain Dan bazian who lied to us about
weapons of mass destruction we fought
all my friends have died over there like
you know and I I just look at what they
provided us with and it's it's it's not
nothing it's like a negative you know
even if they just didn't do jack [__]
that would be you know bad but they've
actually done things to hurt us over and
over and over again so like this whole
thing of they're our greatest allies is
complet fu and you know we send them
$100 billion dollars and they send a
$100 billion dollars and then they
distribute to our politicians and every
politicians will [__] aack Handler walk
around tell them [__] say how vot
he's like the new Hugh Hefner of our age
but the good news is he's saying what
already we know is that this life of
Hedonism is a dark hole so there's a
Muslim that's in touch with him that I
know personally and he's been talking
with him and he hasn't really posted the
henness and stuff for over like a year
and he wants to do things that are more
fulfilling so he was recently I don't
know if you've seen the the interview
some bits of it going around that he's
talking about Muslims are good people
they're [__] of the globe like Corner
glob is Muslim they're all bad guys and
all ter they're actually a pretty
peaceful religion uh he seen past all
the programming the Muslims are
terrorists all Muslims are terrorists is
[__] [__] but that's what
Hollywood keeps [__] pumping out
there is like all every [__] bad guy
in these movies are always these [__]
jotti terrorists you know like they're
always the [__] bad guy and all the
other nonsense that's out there there
was uh we'll show some clips of that but
there was one part of the interview I
want to get your guys perspective
because a lot of people have this
misconception revolving around what
you're going to see in this video clip
you know going to the church and and and
doing all that stuff to me the idea of a
like God that's up there that is
requiring every to worship Him seems a
little strange not saying it's not you
know Cas not sh people religion but it
just to me the more successful people
are like they know the better a fighter
is the L he needs everybody to tell him
how great he is you know and I feel like
if you were God would you really need
everybody to worship you all the time
and tell you how great you are doesn't
seem to you know correlate with the
experience that I've had I feel like
everybody knows the right thing is to do
and just do the like that's my religion
thing you know what it is you know like
I mean every kind of got their comers
sociopath or something like that like so
just do the right thing and you know you
know treat others as you want to be
treated you know I think there's a lot
of knowledge in the Bible there's a lot
of good quotes in there um but as far as
like traditional mainstream religion I'm
not you know power to be anything maybe
Christian you know I like the Muslims I
mean I think they have a pretty peaceful
religion they a really bad rap in the
media um but I'm met a lot of Muslims
and they're you know pretty morally
sound for the most part so you would
consider being a Muslim I don't know
about the religion I I think I'm
probably read the Quran so lot to un
package there so I mean if we want to
start from reverse or forward to help
Dan along the way I would say let's
start from the beginning where he was
saying that he has this difficult time
understanding why a God would need us to
worship him so the first thing to
understand is Allah the Creator the god
the only one Unworthy of worship has no
need of us but we are in need of
worshiping him see when we pray five
times a day it's not that Allah needs it
it doesn't sustain Allah it doesn't make
Allah more powerful but it reminds us
who is our creator who is the greatest
who are the one we're going to return to
if we don't keep that mental check on us
we I mean imagine even with the prayers
and even with the Quran how much of an
ego we have how much pride do we have as
human being beings even knowing that God
is the greatest we have this
misconception of thinking we can do
everything right but as a Muslim when I
put my forehead on the ground Allah
doesn't need that but I need that
humbleness to show myself that look this
life is temporary there is a creator
that created me that I have to go back
to that I have to submit to because that
Creator's laws are how I should live I
don't know best my Creator Knows Best
I need that right so so that's the first
thing to clear up from that
misconception and I'm sure Al is going
to break into that secondly this idea of
just do the right thing everybody knows
what the well that's the thing people
don't what do you mean do the right
thing is abortion the right thing or the
wrong thing now you can talk to
different segments of our country and
the country that we're in right now and
there will be segments that will feel
very morally compelled to say abortion
is the right thing as a woman is right
it's her body it's her choice it's wrong
for you to tell a woman what she can do
with her body and her pregnancy and it's
her right they will morally make that
argument on the other hand other
segments of our countries Christian and
otherwise will very morally say that
abortion is murder it's it's horrible
it's a wrong thing it's AB the right
thing is to condemn it and not allow it
right so you see both sides are using a
moral judgment very different not
everybody if you take about euthanasia
like people who are older whether they
can kill themselves people that are in
pain you will the death penalty you will
find two very morally compelled
different arguments two opposite sides
of the spectrum each one of them will
consider their point to be morally
correct and the last thing I'll say inah
and benefit from our brother is he's on
the right track he said I want to read
the Quran great read the Quran our Our
advice to him is go and read the Quran
and if you have questions reach out to
us we're here to help you answer
questions I mean to say that I guess if
I was going to choose that choose
Christian just because you're from a
Christian background doesn't make sense
in the end you have to choose what's
right you have to choose what's most
just that's most morally correct what's
best preserved that's that's the true
message I mean you yourself were not
raised in an Islamic environment but you
chose Islam right many people may not
realize Ali da Ali brother chose Islam
you know myself I I was raised going to
church but I chose Islam why when I read
the Quran when I read the Islamic belief
it made so much sense it was so clear it
was so correct it was such a Divine
truth that it showed me that all the
corruption the church put in and
synagogues and temples and all that
could not stand to the truth of Islam so
we hope he will continue that path and
actually read the Quran and ask
questions and just like when we saw
Andrew first coming towards Islam it may
be a process but inshallah he'll be
Muslim just like when we saw sneo first
coming to Islam it took months but
alhamdulillah he's a Muslim today we
hope I don't know the brother danian Dan
Missourian inshallah someday will'll be
a Muslim as well I have no idea who he
is by the way the first time I've heard
of him same I I know him I don't know
his name yeah so go ahead what's your
what's your take on that what's your
Insight on some of those touch up on
because just touch upon the thing of um
him saying you know does God need us to
worship him um I I believe this is one
of the issues even even not just for
himself even a lot of Muslims face
there's one aspect ofed we don't really
understand which is that we there is
there is a narration about a group of
angels that were created and their sole
purpose is to be in s from the moment
they are created
to so Allah tells them to lift their
heads up and when they lift their heads
up they say something very interesting
they say Oh Oh Our Lord like we did not
worship you the way you deserve to be
worshiped subh now this is very
interesting because we're talking about
you know some some of us you know we
pray and we think we're a m you know me
pray exra we're talking about a group of
angels who have in s for millions or
billions or God knows how many years the
moment they are told to lift their head
up they say to Allah we did not worship
you the way you deserve to be worshiped
one aspect we don't understand about is
the following we worship Allah not
because what he does for us but because
of who he is like for example when I
speak to people in like non-muslims and
I tell them when you see a famous person
let's say James Bond or whoever it is at
their time um these famous actors you
get excited
oh my gosh like you feel oh my gosh
isn't that isn't that and then you go
when you go next to him your palms are
sweating the respect you have is okay if
I can take a picture the the the respect
you give him and ask a question did this
guy pay your debt did he back you up in
a fight what did he do so much that you
have this level of respect that you
around him it's okay take oh is he okay
[__] why are you who is he what has he
done for you because of he's an actor
who he is now if that's the respect you
give to a human being that is an actor
that you watch and you're excited what
about the one who's created the heavens
and the Earth so it's not that Allah wa
tala needs us Allah doesn't need if
every single human being stopped praying
Allah doesn't need us that's why if we
understand who Allah is and understand
Allah's attributes understand who he
really is we will then grasp that he
deserved worship even if he didn't
command Us in the Quran to pray we would
pray we would bow down because we
believe he deserves that and then just
touching on the morality thing again I
can remember I was having a little
debate with one of these mads yeah um
and um they were mocking Islam they were
look at the Quran the Quran says you
cannot marry your mom h ha or your son
and I was like very interesting you know
why because he was the same person
talking about morality cuz he has no
objective morality he was the same one
who said actually I have morally I
cannot say it is wrong for me to have
intimacy with my own daughter and I
thought Subhan Allah you are mocking the
Quran but the Quran is a solution
because you're telling me there is
nothing wrong with me doing a with my
own D objectively so to me that's the
only thing I can say I mean this is
profound now so um for to have someone
like Dan bazilian now now we have people
Specialists who are in the field of
communicating the message and then God
willing you guys can help get this
message to him to help facilitate an
easy way for him to